les couteaux une interview donc de
l'auteur de haïti steven spielberg qui
vous a tellement impressionné
mesdemoiselles spielberg a fait une star
d'un riz thomas 10 ans c'est lui qui
protège encore il extraterrestre du ciel
il a déjà fait trois films sa petite
partenaires de 6 ans drew barrymore en a
déjà cinq à son actif les vagues et les
filles petites filles et petites nièces
de comédiens célèbres
elle a commencé à jouer à onze mois et
demi
c'est kenny gâtés jobs
seul
encore un mot sur hit et vous l'avez vu
combien de fois déjà autres et vous avez
envie de le revoir mais pourquoi j'ai
souhaité un mois chaque fois que je
revois je ressens quelque chose dans mon
coeur et j'aime bien peut-être france
roche le génie de spielberg est il des
trains mettant en scène avec tout son
savoir-faire tout son savoir carreau il
ya eu en effet aussi aventuré l'arche
perdue il faut quand même mentionné
qu'il a fait un échec commercial
retentissant et 1941
mais peut-être c'est ce qu'il dit dans
ses interviews avec nos confrères de la
presse hebdomadaire
le génie spielberg est il qu'il est
resté un enfant malgré son savoir-faire
d'adultes et qu'il correspond comme il
vient l'expliqué ans qui interviewent
tellement bien à la mentalité la
sensibilité des enfants qu'il arrive
effectivement à produire des images des
sentiments qui les émeuvent
et puis il est resté totalement lui-même
parce que j'ai lu dans un journal
américain une interview de spielberg ou
sa famille expliqué que quand il était
enfant
non seulement il était absolument obsédé
par les films du bing m y faisait des
films de 8 mm à 10 12 ans il les faisait
jouer par ses petits camarades
mais en même temps il n'avait qu'une
seule envie c'était de faire peur aux
gens
autrement dit pour lui le cinéma c'est
une façon absolue de de vivre ce qu'il
voulait faire quand il était enfant
faire peur et faire tourner elle arrive
à faire pleurer c'est à dire
essentiellement ce qu'on disait à propos
de walt disney de hitchcock jouer sur
les émotions d'un sentier c'est un
cinéma d'émotion mais c'est quand même
inquiétant de voir que en grand
amoureuse d'une bec absolument horrible
tout à une série d'enfants dans le monde
et même de grandes personnes parce qu'on
a commencé quand même il ya cinquante
ans à faire des histoires pour enfants
qui avait toujours des petits enfants
pour héros puis on est passé au bec
c'était des souris de mickey à félix
csars passant par miss bibi qui va
sortir en décembre
walt disney nous a fait aimer des bêtes
et maintenant c'est un extraterrestre
est ce qu'on ne pourrait plus trouver
d'amour en dehors de notre planète
mais je crois vous avez aimé aussi bien
il tique le petit enfant elliott aussi
qui joue un rôle très important dans le
film dont justin c'est l'exact référence
pour actifs démonstration france franche
et claire